arrived and suddenly the eyes
of those who disbelieved will
be staring in horror. While
they say, in action, and in
speech. Oh, woe to us, we had
been unmindful of this, rather
we were wrongdoers. This is the
epitome of repentance,
Repentance, as defined by the
prophet
is contrition Meaning, the
epitome of repentance and
everything that comes from
repentance repentance is is
contrition. regret, over what a
person does. Of evil. However,
this contrition is not of
consequence. It's of no
consequence for the people of
the hellfire. Why? Because
repentance is accepted by Allah
wa ta'ala. However, there is a
time when repentance will not
be accepted. The first is a
specific time on the individual
level Second time when Allah
will not accept repentance is a
general time that will apply to
the masses of the people.
masses repentance will no
longer be accepted when the sun
rises from where it sets when
the sun rises from the west. At
that point, no repentance will
be accepted by Allah. Imam
Muslim Allah has collected in
his authentic compilation on
the authority of Abimus Al Ash
Ari. that the prophet said,
Allah most high does extend his
hand at night for the sinner of
the day to repent. And he
extends his hand in the day for
the sinner of the night to
repent. And this continues
until the sun rises in the
west.
The second time, which is
specific to each one of us, is
the time of death when the soul
is, when the soul is being
ejected from the body. When the
soul is being stripped from the
body, repentance will be of no
consequence to a person. That
is, as the prophet said,
selected by Allah, the
authority of Ibn Omar. said
that Allah accepts the
repentance of anyone who
repents as long as they are not
in the throes of death. When a
person is in the throes of
death and their soul is being
ejected from their body, they
are no longer able to repent, a
meaningful repentance. What do
these two times have in common?
These two times have in common
that everyone will repent
Nothing very very special about
these times. Even Pharaoh
Azimandi is has mentioned by
some repented just before his,
just before his demise. When he
was at death's door. This is
not something that is unique to
the believers. Likewise, the
prophet mentioned,
Muslim on the authority of that
the sun will rise from the west
and when the people of the
earth see it, they will all
believe unanimously, all at
once, but Allah will not accept
the repentance of anyone who
has not previously repented.
This is not something unique at
that point in time. Says
Subhanahu wa ta'ala
in response to the people of
the Hellfire. Indeed, you and
what you worship other than
Allah are the firewood of hell.
You will be coming you enter
it.
then he will say, had these
false deities actually been
gods they would not have come
to it, meaning to the hellfire.
He then says but all are
eternal therein. Eternally, the
hellfire will blaze. Eternally,
its inhabitants will inhabit
it. When these verses were
revealed to the prophet Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala described
the state of the people of the
hellfire in the hellfire. He
says, for them, the people of
the hellfire therein, in the
hellfire is heavy sighing. And
they, therein, will not hear.
They will not hear, do to thee.
enormous roar of the hellfire.
They won't be unable to hear
due to the intense unsettling
sound of the hellfire. May
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
protect us all. These verses
were revealed to the prophet
those adversaries of his and
his agonists. Begin to mock
him, mock the Quran and say, if
that is true, meaning that we
and those who we worship other
than Allah will all be in hell
together. Then we will be in
the company of Asab and Mariam,
Jesus, son of Mary, and Hosea.
And his mother Mary, all of
them were worshiped, aside from
Allah. We will be in the
company of the angels. We will
be in the company of, he said
This is a great company for us
to be in Obviously, they said
this antagonizing the prophet
out of mockery. Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala responded to this
silliness and said, indeed,
those for whom the best reward
has preceded from us, they are
far from it removed. They will
not hear its sound while they
are in that which their souls
desire, abiding eternally and
so We understand that those
idols and those objects and
those things that were
worshiped other than Allah and
were pleased with that worship
or worse yet invited to their
own worship These will all be
in the hellfire. As for those
who were worshiped
unintentionally, they did not
desire this nor did they call
to it. Then they will be
removed. from the hellfire and
they will not be afflicted even
with its grueling grinding
sound. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says, abiding eternally.
and so, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has mentioned the people
of the hellfire and the people
of paradise. All are similar in
the fact that they are eternal.
The people of paradise, of
course, their eternity is
radically different than the
eternity of the people of the
Hellfire. However, all are
eternal in their respective
abode.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala did
not distinguish in wording
between the eternity of
paradise and the eternity of
the hellfire. This is the
belief of all of the Muslims.
And this is the belief of the
scholars of that paradise is
eternal and will never come to
an end. Nor will its people
people, its inhabitants, they
will never come to an end,
either.
As for the hellfire, it is
eternal and its people will
remain therein eternally. This
is the belief of the companions
and nothing authentic and
explicit has been collected or
narrated to the contrary. Many
of the scholars have mentioned
this is the consensus of all of
the scholars, the consensus of
all of the Muslimian in the
time of the companions and
their predecessors. And their
successors, excuse me. As was
mentioned by Sheikhul Islam
and others. Some of the
scholars of Islam have
mentioned that Erodice is
eternal and its people will
reside therein eternally and
the hellfire is not eternal.
That it will come to an end
eventually. This opinion is a
weak opinion. And this opinion
is not collected from any of
the companions and is not
distinguished in the Quran.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
explicitly mentioned the
eternity of the hellfire and
its people in three separate
places in the Quran. Surat
Surat Aljin. and the people of
the Hellfire will retain will
remain therein. Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala has negated the
existence of death for paradise
or hell and he has negated the
existence of non existence. So,
a person will not be existent
and then be non existent. This
is a type of death in the Quran
and it has been negated by
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
[Arabic recitation]